this Sunday evening the moon will pass
behind the center of Earth's shadow and
turn a rusty red this is a total lunar
eclipse and while it's not quite as
blindingly impressive as a total solar
eclipse this one is still pretty
spectacular this will be the last in a
series of four total lunar eclipses that
have occurred in the last two years a
rare event called a tetrad and this
lunar event will also occur during a
super moon when the moon passes closest
to the Earth's surface the last time a
super moon eclipse happened was in 1982
and it won't happen again until 2033
during a total lunar eclipse the moon
appears red because of a quirk of
Earth's atmosphere the moon doesn't
totally disappear because while earth
blocks most of the sunlight some
trickles around the edges of the planet
that light gets filtered through the
Earth's atmosphere which only lets
through light with longer wavelengths
that is red light so when you look up to
the sky on Sunday prepare for something
pretty special the moon will start to
pass through the Earth's dark umbral
shadow around 9 p.m. Eastern time and
it'll be completely shaded for about an
hour starting around 10:00 that means
the Eclipse moon will just be rising as
viewers on the west coast tune in keep
an eye on skies
you